everyone good afternoon say a little bit
about myself and the startup I work for
so my name is Kiera Taraka I'm from Pune
India I graduated from the College of
Engineering Pune two years ago and since
then I've been working at the start of
zero labs so we're working on getting AI
on the edge so we're tired of this whole
dependency on the cloud and all your
data going up to the cloud and being you
know sold whoever and none of us get any
of that money right so we want all of
your data all the computation that
happens when you use AI to remain on
your device so the data remains owned by
you and then using the blockchain we're
creating a marketplace where you can
then monetize this data so that anyone
who wants it can only get it from you
and they need to pay you for it so
that's the product they were working on
and we're hoping to have our prototype
out in the next couple of months so
today I'm going to talk to you guys
about numpy so I use it a lot in my work
because a lot of the algorithms that we
write we first test them thoroughly in
numpy because it's the easiest way to
test code because Rob is not gonna sit
and write you know really hardcore C++
code every time you want to test a
certain algorithm because it just wastes
a lot of time so numpy gives us the
flexibility in the ease of use of Python
whereas it's not as computationally slow
as using normal Python would be so put
this tutorial I've got a couple of
Jupiter notebooks that I'm gonna use
which you guys can find at on my github
repo if you follow the link over here so
if everyone has that then get started
how many of you have used to numb by
before with the show of hands okay and
do you guys use a lot of number or do
you just do the length some of the basic
stuffs just using adays and you know
it's just that much has anyone used like
really advanced functions of numpy or
does anyone use it a lot in their work
so I mean I'm gonna sort of cover a lot
of different functions in numpy from
some of the basic ones to the more
advanced ones so that way irrespective
of the level of comfort you have with
numpy by the end of it all of us should
be hopefully at the same level so I'm
going to start off with the fundamental
you know container data structure that's
used in Nampa which is the ND area so
this is there's a couple of ways how you
can you know initialize and create your
added a couple of different functions
you can use so obviously just you know
passing in a list to the NP dot add a
function you can create an array then if
you want to create an array of you know
all one's then it's NP dot once you pass
in the shape you get an area of all ones
and then you do the same thing for zeros
and then I mean a lot of times if if
you're ever using a loop then you
obviously want to be able to iterate for
a certain range so numbers range
function is a range so the parameter
list goes start stop and skip so you
start from element the first element you
go all the way to the last one and if
there's a skip parameter set it skips
that mean elements in between if you
just pass in one function sorry one
parameter it assumes that the others are
zero so you create a range from zero to
nine then if you want one element that
can be a an array or a scalar number to
be repeated and to create a certain
another array with a particular shape
you can use the tile function so here I
want an array of tools and I want the
shape to be five rows and three
so I use NPR tile and n P dot repeat
will repeat each element that is in the
list that you pass it and the second
parameter is the number of times those
elements should be repeated so here I've
got an area with one comma two and I'm
saying I'm saying repeat at five times
so that's how it repeats one five times
and it repeats two five times so you can
see how it's different from the tile
function and another cool thing you can
do is suppose you wanted one repeated X
number of times in two repeated Y number
of times in the second parameter you can
just pass in a list or in this case a
tuple because it's only true where you
specify how many times you want each of
those guys repeated so here one will get
repeated five times and two will repeat
get repeated twice so that's the idea
that gets generated then there's a in be
total in space where it will create an
equally spaced added between the first
parameter one the second parameter of
five and it'll give you an area with ten
elements in between them so here it
calculates the the jump to be zero point
four four four and so on and then it
gives you ten elements each element
space start with that much value and you
can also use NP dot matrix to create a
matrix I like I never use NP dot matrix
and I don't really know many people who
do because you can just do the same
thing with an airy and it's a lot easier
like for NP dot matrix you have to pass
it in you have to pass in the parameters
in this format and I don't know I just
don't like doing that but you know it's
it's there it's an option if anyone
wants to use it so it does the same
thing you can just use NP rot editor do
this and you can also create a
structured array where you can label the
data that you have so you know I know
that's one of the like big benefits of
pandas is that you can have sort of like
structured data label data but you can
have that in numpy as well so here I
pass in the so I'm passing in a list of
tuples where I have the first value in
the tuple to be the label of the data
and passing in and the second value is
the probability of that label so that's
the kind of data that this area is
representing so here that's what I first
pass in so I pass in the list of two
tuples with a 0.8 0.2 that's my data now
we need to tell num by how this data is
being structured because it's a
structured area right and you define
that structure so I define that in the
d-type parameter so here I'm saying that
the first element in the tuple is a
label so that's for the first element
and the type is 8 which is which is
basically a string or it's 8 bytes and
then I say the second element is called
probe and the type is f/8 which is the
float so then when I do that if I had
like a lot more than just two tuples in
there I could get all of the labels by
indexing my array like this just to X of
label and I get the labels and then I
can do X of prob
and I get the probabilities so I mean
this is this is useful if you have like
a lot of tuples of this sort of
structured data and you want to get you
know one particular feature of the
entire data set you can do this now the
probably the most powerful feature of
numpy is it's broadcasting so with that
what it's able to do is take an array of
two different shapes and if they meet
certain conditions which I'll talk about
then it's able to sort of replicate the
smaller array
enough time so that it is compatible
with the first array and you
completed operation so I'll show you how
that works so here this is just a basic
batteries are already of compatible
shapes so then you can just go ahead and
do all of these computations without any
issues so you can just add them you can
add a scaler to it so this this is an
example of broadcasting so you have the
array a which has three elements to it
then you have a scaler one so what this
does is when when numpy sees the scaler
and it needs to add it to a vector it
treats the it vector eise's this
operation so what it does is it takes
the one and it treats it as if it was an
area of three ones because that's the
shape of a and then it adds them one at
a time so it broadcasts one to the shape
of the first operator first operand and
it completes the operation so the same
thing is happening here
a - 9 + and - 10 and these are the rules
for numpy broadcasting so take a look at
the rules and then I have like two
exercises where I mean you guys tell me
whether broadcasting will happen and the
operations will go through so these are
the rules it starts from the last
dimension so the rightmost I mention all
the way to the beginning and it checks
for these two conditions whether the two
dimensions are equal or one of them is 1
so it's two simple rules you start from
the right go to the left the dimensions
should be equal or one of them should be
one so here these are my two arrays one
has a shape of 20 comma 5 and the other
has a shape of 20 comma 1 and I want to
add these two arrays can they be can
they be added will broadcasting take
place over here how many yes and so
there has to be you would think it won't
get broadcasted
so yeah it does get broadcasted and some
does happen properly so the secondary P
which is 20 comma 1 gets broadcasted to
the shape of a 20 comma 5 and the 2
arrays are added okay so this one how
many of you think they can be
broadcasted and gone everyone has to
answer this time ok so how many things
that can't be broadcasted okay so let's
see what happens okay anyone want to
change their mind can be broadcasted
again okay so yeah they can be
broadcasted so if you look at it from
the rightmost dimension over here these
two so the two conditions state that
they should either be equal or one of
them should be one so here this checks
out both of them are equal then you go
to the next one for these two is the
second condition one of them is one then
you come here again the second condition
checks out
one of the dimensions is one then your
both are equal and then again in the
first dimension one of them is 1 so
broadcasting can happen it follows all
the rules of numpy broadcasting okay now
this one
go now everyone should get this yes okay
yes they can be broadcasted so that's
that's it about numpy broadcasting so
you'll find that the more you use numpy
when you have when you're dealing with
larger dimensions and much bigger data
then broadcasting becomes really really
useful and it's a really quick way of
it's a very efficient way of doing a
computation because the alternative
would be to write a for loop and do it
which we all know is really really slow
in Python so numpy takes care of that we
don't have to use for loops if you're
doing this properly so now another cool
thing that number I have numpy has
indexing properties so here if this is
my array of 25 elements now let's say I
want to change the shape of this so that
it has one column as well so I don't
have to call numpy is a V shape function
I don't need to create a new array with
the shape that I want what I can do is
with this sort of syntax with this
indexing syntax I can change the shape
of my numpy array so the first part of
the inside the brackets is the ellipsis
operator so this is saying all the rows
and the second operation a second
parameter is a NP dot new axis so it's
saying that I want a new axis I want a
new dimension created or so on all the
rows plus I want a new dimension so here
it changes the shape of the array to
this so now it has 25 rows and one
column and that's been done without
using any reshape function nothing just
the colon operator and NP new axis you
can also do the same thing by just
passing none
so if I do this it works the same way I
can both ways NP dot new access or none
and then you can add an extra dimension
to it yeah so here I have created
another array and I've passed in the
shape as 5 rows 5 columns and one value
in the third dimension so this is my
array and I can use this operator for my
indexing as well so now there are three
dimensions and if you as you see I
passed only two values in here I mean
normally we think that if I have three
dimensions and I want to index some
value in it I pass in some value for
each of the dimensions so here I'm
saying I want the first row and the
three dots afterward expand into colon
comma colon so it just assumes that you
want everything from the other
dimensions so here I'd get the first row
all the columns and everything in the
third dimension which in this case is
just one so that's why I get these
values so this is the same as doing this
so that means all of you know what the
colon does right everything in this
dimension so either putting the three
dots or two colons gives you the same
result as you can see that now yeah
how many of you guys think this is gonna
work also many times I don't know how
many of you have faced this but I mean I
faced this a couple of times with
certain functions that I've used
I think it's happened a couple of times
with tensorflow if I remember correctly
but when you do some computation the
area that you get returned always seems
to have an extra dimension an extra
unwanted dimension like in the case that
I had before this the third dimension
just had one element in it which is very
pointless it's just annoying to have
that extra dimension when it's just one
value so there are some functions which
return data and this really annoying
format so you can use the number squeeze
function where it will just squeeze out
all of the dimensions that have only
that there are just one so in the case
that we had the 5 comma 5 comma 1 if you
squeeze it it gives you an array of
shape 5 comma 5 so it removes that
unnecessary dimension of 1 so it kind of
helps you clean out the array and makes
a lot easier to use so this is how the
area looks now
so a lot better than how it looked
before and again you can do the same
thing over here now if I for some reason
want that annoying shape again I can use
NP dot new access to get it back and I
mean I don't know why you'd want to do
this but you can that's the point
another really cool thing about the way
you can index is not in Nampa is you can
pass in two lists or as many lists as
required for the number of dimensions
you have so in this case I have two
dimensions so I'd pass in two lists one
list specifies the indices for the row
and the other list specifies the indices
for the columns that I want
to print out or you know take from my
array so here I passed in 0 1 2 3 4
comma 0 1 2 3 4 so in a 5 by 5 array can
anyone just guess what they think this
would return if I indexed an area like
this the first list is the are the
indices for the rows and the second list
is the are the indices for the columns
and it's a five by five array
anyone has any idea what what I'd get
from this operation and without running
it on your sorry
yeah so it gives you the diagonal so
what it does is it takes the first
element of the first list which is 0 so
it says the 0 with Row and then it takes
the first element of the second list
which is the 0th column and then it does
the first row with the first column
second row second column third with
third and fourth with fourth so that way
it index it indexes across the diagonal
so you can pass in any combination of
rows and columns that you want and it
will do it in that sort of 1 is to 1 way
with the rows and columns and it helped
you index through whatever elements of
the adder you want you can also use the
slice operator so you can go from 0 to 2
and index everything from there so here
I have 2 dimensions in this array but I
have passed only one slice to it so what
will do is just give me the Z row with
the second row because it's the first
dimension right so it doesn't know what
I want for the column so it just assumes
I want everything because I haven't
specified it so it will give me the
first and second row so I got the first
and second row now another cool thing
about slicing now I've sliced this
larger array of 5x5 and I have this
smaller array X which has just the first
two rows and now let's say this was like
a 500 by 500 array and I sliced the
array so that I got the first two rows
because I wanted to make some change
the first two rows and I and I didn't
want to you know operate on the entire
large adding so now I can do this I'll
say the zeroeth row and the zero is
column the element over there on this
slice X I wanna change to 100 so I
change it to hundred so now this slice
has been changed X has been changed how
many of you think a will be changed as
well okay how many think a will be
changed and what word do you think will
be changed to of a okay does everyone
agree with what he said and is anyone
disagree with or Deezer
yeah so so yeah it does change and the
reason is that when you so the slicing
operator in numpy was designed to allow
this so that you can instead of having
to operate on an entire large array
suppose I mean you could have cases
where your areas are so large that they
don't even fit in memory I mean we all
know today with the amount of work we do
a data analysis that big data is more
you more often than not have big data
than small data right so there could be
times where I have like a really really
large array
I won't only operate on the top left
corner for some particular things that
I'm doing but I still want my main area
to be affected I don't want to then have
to copy the changes back and go through
all of that so I can just extract a
slice of that array so in this case how
I've done for the first two rows do all
my computation on these two rows
modified over there and then that will
reflect back in the original array so
there are use cases where this is useful
I mean obviously in a case where it's
just a five by five array it really
doesn't make a difference but then I
couldn't show you like a 5,000 by 5,000
area right now but it does extrapolate
those kind of to that to that scale okay
okay quickly any guesses what is the
output of this gonna be
yeah yeah so that's what this expands
into so the : : so basically when you
provide two colons to the parameter for
the index it goes start then the middle
is stopped and the last one is the skip
in between similar to the arrange format
so what this does is if I passed in
nothing for the first two it assumes
beginning to end so it says okay on
index in my rows from the beginning to
the end and I want every other row
I mean or every other element in this
dimension so had it been three able to
give me a beat third and fourth so on
and then we know from the previous
example that when you have a list of row
indices and a list of column indices it
goes in a one is to one manner and
indexes everything in that order so here
it gives me every alternate row and from
every alternate row the first
I mean index number one index three and
index four so that's how I get this now
suppose you wanted to instead of having
this row and column indexing type in a
one is to one way suppose you wanted to
have it like a cross-product
so the first row I mean the first index
in the list for the rows with every
element in the list for the columns and
then the second guy in the rows with
everyone in the columns in the third and
so on so you'd use this function called
NP dot IX underscore so what did we do
here is you have 0 2 for the rows and 0
2 3 for the columns and it gives you an
index like this so what this translates
into is 0 with row with 0 second and
third column and second row with 0
second and third column so then now when
I pass in this this tuple of rows and
columns to the as the index for the
array a this is how and you see the
hundred is there because of
a previous example so this is how the
returned a day looks so it's got the its
it's indexed it like a cross product ok
this I'm gonna I mean quickly I'm gonna
give you guys two minutes you need to
add the to a dish together and remember
how we're supposed to remember what is
the Lord for broadcasting and then using
what we know about indexing give me the
first and last element of every
alternate row so I mean if you don't
have your laptop then you obviously
can't so try and do it in your head if
you do have your laptop then you don't
have a way of getting out of it so and I
mean whoever gets it first just tell me
what it is I'll write it out and then we
can see whether it runs on what
because anyone have you did
anyone
yeah
so just tell me I'll type it up okay
yeah so okay so let me let me let me
rephrase the question
do this thing without using reshape yeah
so anyone did it without reshape and
then have you done the indexing as well
so then you can just add the indexing to
this because I want the first and last
element of every row right so what would
I pass into the index to get that
yeah yeah so that's how you do it so you
first have to make this make sure the
shapes can be broadcasted so that means
you need to add the new axis to here
then you add B to it and then you can
dex it in this way so it's just like the
example we did before every alternate
row and then you pass in the columns
that you want so that's the basics for
the ndra broadcasting and indexing so
these are like the fundamental features
of numpy and what makes it really
awesome to use now going one level above
this is a-you funks and stripe tricks
and I in some so stride tricks like I
really really like a lot I had like a
lot of trouble when I first started
using stripe tricks it took me like a
really long time to figure out exactly
why it was happening the way it does and
I was really bad at it but once I sort
of once I thought about the hang of
forstride tricks then like I saw it
started doing it just for fun even when
I didn't really need to I just you know
start writing stuff and then using
straight tricks to to create like new
areas so once I go through the you
thunks I'll talk about straight tricks
and hopefully you guys like it too so
you're on I just want to start off with
a small comparison between functions in
Python and the equivalent functions in
numpy so we saw before when you can
create an array using a range to get a
range of elements from a particular
start and stop
so we found a range of 100,000 elements
of 0 to 9 9 9 9 if I want to do that in
numpy I just use n pirata a range and if
I wanted to do it in Python I'd create
the range I get a generator object from
range and then I'd pass that to a list
so they gave me the entire list and now
I'll run this and you can see the
difference in time that it takes so here
it takes one millisecond to Road an
umpire and it takes 6 times that amount
to do it in Python so that's just 6
times slower for I mean no benefit then
for the numpy if you want to sum up all
the elements in this area so you want to
sum up the hundred thousand elements you
use NP dot some and you pass in the area
that you want to sum up and it takes six
hundred and eighty eight microseconds
and now the same thing if I wanted to do
it with my Python list I'd have to
create a loop and sum it all up and that
takes eighteen milliseconds which is an
entire order of magnitude slower then
doing a numpy and a lot more effort to
run an empire and same way I got the
function for taking the average of
everything in the array one point three
eight milliseconds and this is how I'd
have to do it if I was doing it in just
Python and it takes thirty six point
five milliseconds thirty-six times
slower okay now the fire so we all know
that there's a Python function for abs
and there's also a number I function for
abs so based on the two examples we've
seen before
answer the next question and based on
this
so the normal Python ABS on - 3.14159
takes 12 point - my microseconds but NP
dot ABS on the same value takes sixty
two point nine microseconds now based on
all of that which of these do you think
is faster taking the Python ABS on a
list or numpy ABS on the list now what
I've done is just to make it cooler it's
not just a list of five elements
it's that list repeated a hundred times
so it's now it's a fairly large list to
it so now what do you guys think which
will be faster the first one the second
one pythonic or nom pipe okay how many
people number
and it's actually slower yeah I mean not
buy too much but yeah it is slower and
you know how I was surprised too when I
saw this it first say I mean you do get
the same same result from it all but why
is the Pythian one faster than number so
now do the same thing with a small
change so instead of it being a list
with four five hundred elements in it
it's a number array with five hundred
elements in it and I'm doing the same
thing the Python abs in this list
comprehension and the number abs except
it's on a non PI re instead of a Python
list now which do you guys think was
going to be faster numpy or python so
number okay and yeah number is faster so
the number ABS function works
efficiently on number arrays so in the
previous case what did you do is convert
the list into an umpire array and then
do numpy rot ABS on it which is why you
have that small overhead whereas in the
pythonic way it doesn't have any extra
thing to do right it just does abs on
each element on the list so that's why
number ABS was slower on non numpy data
structures okay now for stripe tricks
yeah so this is the area that I have
it's just a range of 10 elements 0 to 9
and how many of you have ever had to
create like a sliding window on an array
and or like reshape it and then yeah
exactly right so I mean how would you
normally do it I mean most intuitive way
of doing it would be to you know do it
in the loop and then sort of create a
new array of whatever shape with
whatever window and slide we want right
so so I used to do it as well and then
one day I was writing code and I
my boss to verify and I didn't this ugly
for-loop with this whole little thing in
it and then he send it back to me with
just one line which is the line after
this I was really confused so I googled
it try to figure out why it was
happening this way how this works and
took me a while to understand but then
once I did that's the only way I was
sliding windows now or any time I have
to do anything similar to a sliding
window I only do it using straight
tricks so here so the functions n P dot
live God's tried underscore strict start
as underscored strided so the first
thing I pass in is the area that I want
to create the sliding window for now the
next thing I do is pass in the shape so
now let's say I wanted to create a
sliding window over this array where the
window size is 4 and it slides two
elements at a time so now my resultant
array would be n number of rows and each
row would have four values in it right
because my window is four now what you
need to do is calculate how many rows
this resultant array is gonna have so if
I have ten elements I want four values
per window and I want a total of I mean
the total number of windows is going to
be based on how many times I want the
slide tap in right so you can use this
simple formula to get the shape of the
result in that way so the length of the
original array - the size of the window
plus one for the number of rows and the
columns is just the size of the window
so in this case it'll be ten minus four
plus one so that's seven comma four is
going to be the seven yeah seven comma
four is the shape of the resultant array
and now the next parameter is
interesting this is the stripes so when
numpy when you create a number array it
so you can see over here when I create
this array it has an attribute called
stripes
so here it's eight so what is telling
number is in memory where you stored
this data
to go to the next element in the list
you your stride needs to be 8 bytes so
when you move eight bytes we get the
start of the next element in the list
and then you go eight bytes again and
you'll get the next element in the list
so now when you create this new
sliding-window array you are essentially
modifying these two parameters of the
original numpy array that you have so
that when numpy reads this array back it
sees the new shape and it sees the new
stride so it's still operating on that
same block of memory so if it was just
one straight block of memory before it's
still the same one block of memory now
the only difference is the way numpy
interprets this memory when you access
it so it doesn't see this memory as an
array of length of shape ten comma none
it now sees it as an array with a shape
seven comma four so it knows it keeps
that in mind when you access for when
you ask it for an element and now it
needs to know how much how much memory
to move to get the next element in the
list right so now initially when it was
just a flat-out array of integers or
floats one after the other it knew okay
if I go eight bytes forward I'll get the
next element and so on but now when we
have a sliding window I'll just run this
so you can see the how it looks so the
first element in the list is zero now
the second element in the array is one
so how much did the let's let's say that
there's a pointer at the beginning of
the memory location how much did the
pointer need to move to get the second
element in the list exactly you need
move eight bytes and you got the second
guy so in the first dimension you need
to move eight bytes to get the next
element in the list so that's how you
get zero one two three you go eight
bytes at a time now in the second
dimension which is in this case one
that's the next element in the next
dimension how many bytes did the pointer
have to move to get one
sorry no it had to move it to go to the
next one in the first in the row so now
to go to one in the column how much does
it have to move again just eight bytes
right because the next element in the
row and the next element in the column
both are just eight bytes away in
original memory so you tell numpy now
that my strides are going to be eight at
a time along the rows and also eight at
a time along the columns right because
you see the columns of score 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 and the rows 0 1 2 3 so in both cases
is just going 8 bytes at a time to get
the next element so my new strides is
the original a dot strides which is
which is 8 comma nothing times 2 so now
the strides are 8 comma 8 so that's why
when I pass in the appropriate strides
and shape it gives me this so I have 0 1
2 3 1 2 3 4 2 3 4 5 and so on all the
way to 9 now the next part of my sliding
window was the slide so here it's just
got the window but there's no slide so
what I do is I go back to the way we did
our indexing before and now I say ok if
this is the adding give me every
alternate row or give me or give me
every row with a jump of s which is the
slide that I defined as 2 and then I get
this so I get my sliding window 0 1 2 3
2 3 4 5 4 5 6 7 & 6 7 8 9 and all of
this is done without creating a copy of
the array it's all done on the same
memory location so it's a really
efficient and fast way of creating a
sliding window so you don't have to do
any for loops you don't have to create a
new array none of that so it's a really
efficient and fast way of doing sliding
windows so I mean the part that I was
really confused about and which I had
trouble with was understanding the
strides because I mean if you look at
the documentation for this function they
don't really talk well about what the
strides is doing so it doesn't it's not
really clear how to X
extend this for examples with larger
dimensions but the trick is to always
like sort of picture it and look at it
this way so you look at the next element
that you want in the same row and look
at your original array and then count
the number of jumps that you need to
make to get it
and you do the same thing for the
columns and that becomes the new value
of strikes so over here if you pass in
like an incorrect value for strikes so
if I just passed in like eight you get
an error it won't let you do it if I
passed in here to start accessing memory
that is well it's garbage data because
this area doesn't own that memory so I
just go into the next location is just
finding random values and putting it
there so the reason why the previous
time in gave gave us an error is because
the strides had only one value in it
whereas there should have been two
because the shape was defined as
two-dimensional in the second case it
didn't throw an error because the shape
is two-dimensional the strides are also
two-dimensional but the values are
incorrect which is why it didn't give me
an error but it gave me wrong results
yeah and I mean I didn't mention this
before but so the colon colon I mean
this is why we have the colon colon
operator it's because the third operator
was used a lot so at the request of
developers the third argument was added
to the two colons
yeah so you can do the same thing in
three dimensions as well so I have an
array of shape five by four and now I
want to change it so that I take so when
I I want to basically change the shape
so that the resulting shape is 15 to 2
and the strides are like this so then
now when you see the result in terrain
here so I have my first element as 0 and
the next element is 1 so in that
dimension which is the third dimension
from my original array how much did I
have to move so I moved 8 bytes because
that's what I that's how the original
array has been defined in the second
dimension which is out here so I moved 8
bytes to go from 0 to 1 then in the
second one I'm the second one is 4 so I
go 0 1 and in the second dimension I go
0 to 4 so in my original array 4 is in
the second row so that's 32 bytes away
from 0 so that's why the second start is
32 and then again the second value out
here the first element is 1 which is
again just eight bytes away from the
first element of the first array which
is why the result in strides are 8 32 8
so if you do it this way then it becomes
a lot easier to figure out what the
strike should be and you'll very rarely
if at all make a mistake with the
strides so that's what I had trouble
with initially then this really helped
me get correct
this is how the numpy array looks in
like this is the way it's defined so
it's a it's an object that has your data
a pointer to is like a character pointer
then it has a descriptor for the array
it has the dimensions it has the strides
and it has the base and it has a flag so
here if you want to see what those
values are you can there's an attribute
underscore underscore array interface
where it will show you what these values
are so this one for 0-6 blah blah is the
starting location in memory for the data
of X false is a parameter that defines
whether the array is read-only or not so
it's true that means the data is read
only if it's false that means it's read
and write so by default it's obviously
you can read and write to your arrays so
the descriptor is talking about the data
type so here it's saying it's so I eight
is just integer eight bytes then the
shape which is ten strides none and
version is so the payara object
different versions for that so three is
the latest version running an umpire's
pyari object so that is the version that
you see over here so then now if I do
this try tricks on it and I create a new
array Y which is which now looks like
this this is the new array Y which has
been created using straight tricks and
now if I pass know if I've called this
parameter array on disk around square
interface how many of those parameters
in the structure do you think have
changed
so there's Dao descriptor shape Strides
type string version so how many of you
think data will change does anyone think
data is going to change will the star
location be different anyone so everyone
thinks it's going to remain the same
will the description change yes or no
yes no with the shape change how many
four know will the strides change yes
will the next two things change
come on des will the next two things
change yes or no
and there you go so the so data did not
change because like I said its operating
on the same piece of memory it's just
changing this description so that when
numpy reads it back it knows that this
is how it needs to interpret this block
of memory as an area with shape 9 comma
2 and strides as 8 comma 8 and the
location of memory is the same because
we're not creating any copies are not
duplicating it none of that so it's the
same thing now now for fine some how
many of you have used in some before
[Music]
have you guys order find some or like
Einstein summation yeah so so I mean I
in some is really cool function where
you can basically do auditions and
multiplication using the Einstein
notation for it so here is a comparison
with standard numpy you funks and i in
some equivalents and i in some is also
really efficient because what i'm some
does is if when you're doing computation
it doesn't create any copies in memory
so it's really efficient it's it's
memory efficient because no additional
copies are being created so whatever
operations are being done are happening
on the original arrays itself so here if
you just want to create a copy or you
want the equivalent of a dot view which
is just printing out the whole array
itself you do it like this so an
Einstein notation so this these are my
two arrays a and B so both of them are
two dimensional arrays of three rows and
three columns so now in Einstein
notation you pass in a string which in
this case is I comma J and then you pass
in the matrix the array
whether it's one or two you pass in how
many our
raise you want to be operating on so
what I command J means is for every
dimension the character is the next one
starting from I so here in this case I
have two dimensions so the first
dimension I referred to as I the second
dimension is J and the area is a so here
it's saying give me everything that's I
and give me all eyes and all jails of
area so it gives me all the rows and all
the columns of array here which is how I
get this so it's just returning the same
area yeah yeah pretty sure it has to be
just ijk but we can we can check it I
think it does have to be just i JK
so if I do I think it's just convention
to use a IJ K L and so on so in most
cases you'll find it's just I Jake here
and I mean I think we can test this
whether you can use numbers as well no
you can't use numbers so it's characters
and I mean in generally use inj so if
you want the same thing and like an
equivalent function in numpy would be
just to get the view of the area and
here you can see it it's faster because
it's not really doing anything is just
giving you a view on the same area so
there's nothing but so there are some I
on some functions which are a lot more
efficient then then on by equivalents
but there are also some numpy functions
which are faster than then some
equivalence and i have a few examples of
those as well and then we can talk about
why it is that they're more efficient
then i in some because i assume was
written to be a more efficient
alternative to the standard numb by
functions so here if i wanted to do a
transpose so it goes in alphabetical
order so it knows that I is the is
supposed to be the first dimension and J
is supposed to be the second dimension
but here what I passed in is the
I've set J and followed by I so what it
does is it takes so when it returns from
this function it takes the second
dimension and the first dimension and
switch it around so it gives me the
transpose so here I bought the transpose
of matrix a and if I will do the same
thing in normal Python I get I can I get
the transpose and it's much faster
because when you do a dot T or arrow
transpose it's not doing any operation
on the array just like we've seen with
stri tricks it just in memory changes
the description so that it has new shape
new strides and it returns it like that
so this is like literally no computation
happening on it which is why it's faster
than the eye on some equivalent so the
same way you can now also find the
diagonal of the matrix so so here the
notation is III so it's saying in the
first dimension I want so in the first
and second dimension I want the same
values and it should return only one of
them so that's how it gives me the
diagonals so same row same column give
me all those values so
I get that now what I can also do is if
in Einstein notation so we arrow the
left hand side of the arrow and Einstein
notation is telling numpy which
dimension mean it needs to operate on
and on the right hand side it specifies
how the result should look so in general
so suppose I had like an I comma J arrow
I so what it says is all rows all
columns but when you return it to me
return only the rows so when you leave
out and when you leave out a letter it
assumes that you want it to be summed
across that dimension so if you have no
letters then it just assumes you want to
sum everything so leaving on something
means summation in Einstein notation so
here if I just say I I when I had the
arrow I it would give me the diagonal so
if I remove that and just have I I it'll
sum up the elements across the diagonal
because I haven't specified anything on
the right-hand side of the arrow so it
just assumes I want the sum and it sums
it up for me
so here when I did the diagonals
again you can see it's comparable yeah
so here this is one of the things that's
faster to do using iron some because
you're like actual computation is
happening it's summing up values across
the diagonals and it's faster than
yeah I mean it's almost the same it's
slightly pockets it's pretty comparable
to doing it either way which is unlike
the previous functions we saw like
transpose and what is the first one view
in those cases you could see that there
was no benefit of doing a 9 sum here you
have some benefit of doing an eye on
some and with larger dimensions you will
see more of a benefit again here it's
just a 3 by 3 matrix so when you're
working in such small dimensions it's
it's really hard to gauge how efficient
or how much of a speed benefit you're
going to get when you go into higher
dimensions higher values then you'll see
an improvement
so yeah so all of these I mean most of
these functions that the ones I'm going
through like if I want to multiply these
two on larger data it is faster but
another reason why you do sign sum over
normal vampire is not just for speed
it's for memory efficiency because I'm
some doesn't create temporary copies in
between so like if I had this example
over here where I wanted to do the
matrix multiplication of a and B so
normally in numpy I could use the add
operator or I could use dot or mat mul
and in 9 Sam I'd do it this way so I'd
say for the first array for the first
matrix a I've called it as I comma J
that's however denoted the rows and
columns for the second one I've said J
comma K so now over here you see two I
mean both in both the matrices one of
the dimensions has been referred to with
the same character so what it does is
and now I've omitted that character on
the right-hand side of the arrow so what
it tells is um is you need to sum up the
result along this dimension so the
dimension that is common on the left
hand side and is treated is taken
together and since it's omitted on the
right hand side you sum it up along
there so we know that's how we do matrix
multiplication right so you take
the column of the first the number of
columns in the first matrix needs to be
equal to the number of rows in the
second so that's why you have I J and J
K and then you do an eye on K because
along the columns of the first and the
rows of the second you do your summation
so here
so here you have a handsome is actually
faster
and run it again and now it's slower but
I mean this makes more sense the
previous one because NP dot dot is not
written in normal Python numpy it's
optimized and written in glass so NP dot
dot is supposed to be one of the faster
functions in numpy so eins um when it
was written from then itself it was
known that Hine some would not be able
to perform compatibly to NP dot dot
because it's written in Python and numpy
whereas NP dot dot is written in blast
or m KL whatever you know your platform
support so it's very optimized code so
that's why it'll be very hard for you to
find functions that are faster than dot
and not sure which are the other
functions that are written in blast but
then there are like as you all know many
number functions are written in
low-level C and blasts which is why it
gives you that big speed-up as compared
to normal
Python so here like one area where n sum
is useful is if you were to take an
example of a convolution operation if
you want to do a convolution operation
just an umpire you can do it using
straight tricks and hind sum so I mean
does everyone know what convolution is
okay I mean just in case there's anyone
who doesn't know what convolution is
this is how it works
yeah so on the bottom you have the first
matrix so I'm just gonna call that
matrix a on the top you have the kernel
so or you can call it matrix B but in
general when you talk about convolution
you always have a matrix and you have a
kernel and you apply the kernel on to
the matrix so here we can just talk
about it as a and B so what it's
supposed to do is you so if you can see
the blue elements is the first matrix
and the green one is the second one so
what what in when you do convolution you
expand the boundaries of the first
matrix and there are different schemes
that you can use to expand it either
with all zeros or you can just replicate
the elements that are at the boundary of
the base array so you increase the size
and then you take the top array and just
like it's showing over here you sort of
superimposed the top area onto the
bottom you would do an element wise
multiplication of all of them and then
you sum it up and that becomes the value
at that point and then you slide it to
the with whatever slide you want so here
is just doing it with the slide of one
you can change it to a slide of two
three four whatever you want and you'll
accordingly get the new shape of the
resultant so then here it slides it
again does the multiplication
element-wise sums it up and that's the
new next element in the resultant array
and so on so that's what that's how the
convolution is happening
so now if I wanted to do this so here I
mean here's another example of how
convolution is acting so here in this
scheme it's been expanded by multiplying
with all zeros so i adding all zeros to
it so when you take the kernel which is
on the left hand side you take starting
with 2215 one you would initially
multiply it with the top left so you
would initially take this and multiply
it with these elements then you take
this and multiply it with the first
column onwards like this in the second
and so on then you come down here or
multiply it like that then you finally
come down here multiplied it like this
you don't element wise multiplication
and then you sum it all up and that's
the value at the location so here if I
had this matrix so this is the matrix
and this is the filter that I want to
apply to it now I want to do a
convolution of this small filter or 3x3
onto that large array of five by five so
the first thing I need to do is I need
to source
so using numpy I take the first array
and then I create a bunch of sub
matrices so that I can take the kernel
and multiply it onto each of the sub
matrices and then sum it all up and then
the resultant would give me my
output so to create submatrices is just
like reading a sliding window right so
you have a particular window in this
case it's one and you have a particular
shape that you want the result in to be
n and we can use try tricks for that so
here for that you need a so similarly to
the previous example of stri tricks we
computed the resultant shape by taking
the length of the original subtracting
the window and adding one so here I take
the shape of the original because it's
two-dimensional subtract the shape of
the filter which is the window and I add
one to it so that's how I get the
resulting shape and for the strides in
this case I just want a so here I'll
just print
yeah so 3x3 is the shape of the filter
and now the resultant convolution the
the convolve result would have a shape
of three by three by three by three so
if you were to take the original five by
five array then take the three by three
kernel and actually like using pen and
paper try and figure out what the
resultant would be if you were to take
the first one then slide it with one
multiplied again and so on you would see
that the resultant array would have a
shape of three by three by three by
three there's no the result Andheri
sorry the sub matrices that you're
multiplying would have a three by three
by three by three and when you need to
stride over the sub matrices these are
the strides again I mean again it's
it'll be a lot easier to visualize if
you you know to flick your pen and paper
and draw out the matrices then you'll be
able to see how the resultant shape and
the so another resultant shape the shape
of the sub matrices and the strides
along the sub matrices would be like
this so this is how the sub matrices
look so the first sub matrix you need to
multiply the corner with is this and the
second is 1 2 3 6 7 8 11 12 13 and then
2 3 4 7 8 9 12 13 14 so if you look at
the first area of length 25 shaped as
five by five you'll see that the first
like when you draw it out and you take
the top left corner of three by three
that's what you get and then you move it
by one to the right and those nine
elements are what you get and then again
you move it and these nine elements are
what you get and I mean in that in that
fashion you keep sliding it across the
original array and those are the sub
matrices that the second matrix of 3x3
needs to be multiplied with so using
straight tricks I've expanded the not
expanded technically I've changed the
view on this array so that it's treated
as an expanded version of the original
so that it's easy now to then just
multiply the second matrix onto this
No I abused tried tricks right so
there's been no data copying it's just
those parameters of strides and shape
have been changed so that when numpy
interprets it it knows how it knows to
interpret it like this so that would
mean that's what makes it really
efficient right you don't have this
unnecessary extra memory wasted now I
use n sum to do the multiplication so
the first IJ is talking about the
convolution filter which is the second
the smaller matrix so here I'm saying I
have two dimensions and they're inj now
I want my sub matrices again was a shape
3 3 3 3 right so that's why i've used i
j k l now I want the so here I have like
here if this was the so now if I'm
talking about just the last guy then I
want to multiply the filter with these
values right so I need a multiplied with
with all the rows and all the columns so
that's why I and J I and J are common
and they're left out on the right-hand
side which means they're summed up along
these values so then now when you print
out the convolved result this is what
you see so the last element 182 if you
look at the convolved the filter which
is 1 1 0 1 2 3 0 1 1 182 would be that
filter multiplied by this sub matrix you
multiplied my element by element and
then you sum it all up and you'd get the
value 182 and the same way for all the
other values you'd go to that sub matrix
multiply it with the kernel sum it all
up and that's the value you find in your
convolve result so that's how you can do
a pretty intense operation like
convolution just in number using iron
cements try tricks and here neither iron
some nor try tricks uses any memory
copies to do it
so it's very memory efficient so if you
were doing this on much much larger data
you wouldn't have the unnecessary
overhead of creating a whole bunch of
sub matrices and just wasting a lot of
memory in the process so it's a pretty
efficient way of doing an operation like
convolution yeah sorry these aren't the
indices these are the actual values in
the editor so these are the actual
values of the area that I want to
multiply with the corner I mean yeah
they look like indices because it's 0 25
but this is the actual data that I want
to multiply with the kernel matrix okay
so this is an exercise for all of you to
do so you have an array yeah sorry here
I didn't I mean if you wanted to do that
then you could use one of the number by
function row so there's an umpire or pad
function where you can specify how you
want the padding to be done like how
many elements on the left you want
pattered how many on the right so that
depends on the sort of why you're doing
the convolution so if the use case
you're doing needs the convolution to be
done with elements padded around then
you'd have to pad them you can use numpy
dot pad to do it but here I was just
showing you the basic convolution
operation which is you apply the sliding
window on each element of the area but
yeah there's an umpire dot pad function
where you can do it so yeah this is for
all of you to do so area of 15 elements
if the window it so the window size is 3
the jump is 2 and then find the mean
along the row of the last two elements
in every alternate row and yeah that's
the answer so all of you try it and I
mean hopefully all if you get the
correct answer so I'll give you like two
minutes to try this out
on to the next thing because we're
running short of time so you just tell
me when when you're done with this
Oh is anyone have any trouble with this
then I mean I can help you out after the
tutorial so I'm just gonna move on to
the next next topic and I mean all of
you make sure you try this either now or
when we're done and if you need any help
just feel free to talk to me any time
you see me so so now I'm gonna yeah so
if any of you have ever tried creating
your own sort of class that you want all
the properties of numpy to be there but
then you have some additional features
that you want to sort of impose on this
class then numpy mix-ins is a pretty
cool way to do it so like I'll tell you
some example of how I've used it so why
the I mean what doing some of the work
that I've been doing we needed a basis
create data structure that follows a
certain property of all values when you
take the sum they should be one so
irrespective of the size of the array
the shape of the ADI when you sum it all
up the value should be one so that was
the property that this data structure
always needed to follow for it to be
valid at the same time I wanted to be
able to do non PI operations on it I
wanted to be able to use n P dot sum and
NP dot add subtract all of this stuff
but I still wanted this property of the
sum should be one to be maintained so
for that instead of creating my own
class where I had all of these functions
defined on like repeatedly like I'd have
to create my class call it in this case
probability distribution function then
create a function called add which would
add all of them and then you know sort
of make sure that this property was
maintained then if I needed to use it I
do my class dot add on these two on the
two arrays but instead I want the ease
of being able to do NP dot add and n P
dot mean and whatever other numpy
functions I want but I also want my
property of the sum to be one to be
maintained so for that when you create a
class you
headed from this NP road lived or
mix-ins door NPA di operators mixing so
what this does is it brings in all of
the numpy you func capabilities so you
funks are NP rotted subtract multiply
divide all of these functions there are
unary functions so all of them are all
of them come from mixin so now all of
these functions are available to my
class and I still have the flexibility
of imposing whatever properties I want
and whatever unique features I want on
to this class so here I do that through
the in it so here i've defined this as
i've defined at a unit called PDF where
it would be an adding of probabilities
and as we all know probability value
should never exceed 1 now i want to add
one more step to it so I've made it a
probability distribution function so the
sum of all of these value should always
be 1 for it to be valid so I just make
sure that check has been handled in the
init so that when you create an object
of this class and you pass in data to it
it should follow this property now if I
did like an NP dot add on to objects of
this class numpy doesn't care what these
arrays are right numpy doesn't care that
i want them to be summed up to one
that's on me
so if I were to just use NP dot add on
two values I'd very likely get values
that don't sum up to one so how do I
impose this property on my class so with
with NP dot left guard mix-ins you get
access to this function underscore
underscore area under score you func
underscore underscore and this is the
function that is called whenever you
call an umpire you func function like if
you call NP dot add it goes here and
then it does the ad and if you call
subtract it goes here and then it does
it so if you see in the parameter you
have so in the parameter list you have
you func method inputs and kW arcs which
takes care of all the parameters
you'd have if you were to call NP rotted
or whatever right you pass in the inputs
then the method is NP r dot ad you'd
pass in your KW args and it would do the
addition so this is where you add in all
of your extra logic to make sure that
this object and this class conforms to
your rules even when you do a numpy
functions on them so here the first
thing you do is if you like you know
with our NP dot add and all these you
folks you have the option of passing in
an out parameter so if you want to add
two arrays and store it in a third array
you can pass in the third array to the
NP dot add call and it would store it
there so here the first thing you do is
check whether the you func has any of
these areas that you need to store the
data in and if it does you you find you
like basely extract all of those areas
from the from the KW args
then what what I'm doing is I'm making
sure that whatever data is being passed
into these functions should conform to
my rules they should they should be off
the data types that I support so here
i've defined cell toward handled types
to be just an ND area and an object of
type probability density function so i
don't want to be able to add a list to
this i don't want anything that's not an
that's not an umpire array or a PDF
object to be allowed in a you func so
none of that can happen if anything
that's passed in so if i try doing an NP
dot add on a number array and sorry it's
not an umpire if i try doing an NP dot
add on an object of my class with a list
it would just give me an order
implemented error because that's not
something i support now the next thing
it does is i need to extract the PDF
object the PDF variable from all the
parameters that are of type probability
density function because if it was an
umpire array then I just take the array
itself but if it's a object of this
class then I need to take then I
my input is not the object it's the
array that's part of the object so I do
X dot underscore PDF if it's an instance
of probability density function
otherwise I just take X because by this
point you know that it's either going to
be a PDF or it's going to be an umpire
address so there's nothing else you need
to worry about now here when I now I
need to set the out parameter so now
here the out parameter would be the area
of the object if it's an object of the
class or it would be the area itself if
it's just an umpire area so that's the
check I put in over here so if this was
if if this was just a normal num if this
was just the normal numpy area under
score you func function you wouldn't
have this X dot PDF out here right
because it would just be X because the
input that's coming in is just an umpire
array and whatever data you need to be
needs to be put in there will just go
into the array itself right but because
it's because I also want to handle
objects of this class I need to change
the value so that it's the object it's
the array that's stored within the
object that is being passed into the you
func for the downstream so then now now
that I have done whatever modifications
to the input and output that I need to I
have my inputs are just numpy arrays and
my output is an umpire array right
because I've I've extracted the number
array from the object that's been passed
in so now I can call now I can safely
call the number you funk because it's
just gonna operate on to an umpire
arrays so then I do that through this so
you call the gate attribute you use the
gate attribute function and you pass in
the u function method and then to that
you pass in the inputs and the optional
arguments and then whatever result it
returns is the result that you would get
when you added the underlying data of
the objects and the number array with
whatever method you are using now when
this returns there is no guarantee on
whether my data will all
for my rules of adding to 1 right so I
need to impose that rule on it which is
why when I return it I create I create
an instance of my object and pass in
this data to it so that when the
instance is created in my init function
it handles the case that the sum is not
1 and it sums it to 1 and then returns
it to me so this way when I add 2 when I
add an object of my class the number
array or add 2 objects of my class I can
use a standard number you funk and still
get a result that conforms to my rules
so here
so here this is the PDF that I've
created it's just an area of 0.25 so it
sums up to 1 and now if I want to use
numbers you found on it I mean you
usually wouldn't be able to do this
because if I hadn't defined that you
func intercept function and I hadn't
inherited from mix-ins numpy dad would
throw an error because it has no idea
what two objects of type probability
density function are doing in its
function because it it doesn't know how
to operate on it right it doesn't know
how to interpret it but now since I've
defined that the first thing I'll do it
is we'll go into my definition of you
funks and then it'll add it together
so here the resultant is still point two
is
so here the original array was in this
case was actually 0.5 we here is 0.5 and
the shape was 2 2 so when you add it
together it became 1 1 1 1 right if you
add point 5 plus 0.5 became 1 1 1 1 when
you add those together the sum is
obviously greater than 1 so when I
returned from area underscore you func I
create a new instance of the class right
so when it creates the new instance of
the class it comes here it sees that the
values don't add up to 1 so it divides
it by the sum and therefore now the sum
has become one because it's 0.25 plus
0.25 plus 0.25 plus 0.25 so here you can
see how when you call this function it's
going into my array you func call
I don't have my debugger setup here but
when you call numpy road you found the
first thing that it does is it comes
here then you do all of this it is it'll
extract the PDF object from sorry the
PDF variable from the object and it'll
pass that into to then NP dot add and
then when it returns it it'll again pass
it back to my object so that it does
whatever conformance checks it needs to
and then that's the result I get so
that's how mix-ins work so you can use
this to create sort of more complex
classes that will be able to support
numpy functions but then also have any
additional properties that you want to
have so one more thing i wanted to talk
about is a memory map files so you're
working with like really really large
data in numpy so you can use memory map
files so here the shape of this area is
10,000 by 10,000 and i'm not sure if
this is actually supported or not like
if you wanted to do it normally but if
you go to larger array sizes you'll find
you get memory errors because numpy
can't allocate that large chunk of
memory for your object in which case
you'd you'd wanna so what you can do is
just have that data in a file and then
using number access portions of that
data from the file do all your
modifications and then it'll get written
back to that file so instead of creating
a big chunk of memory while you're doing
a program you will just use that file as
your memory
so here I've created a file called big
file and it was initially created to
have all zeros in it so so all ones so
if you look at it this is the file this
is the large it just printed it from
memory so it's mapped this so this file
is mapped to this piece of data where
it's all ones of shape 10,000 comma
10,000 so now if I wanted to sort of
operate on
this portion of data I just wanted the
first two rows first two columns and
I'll do whatever to it so then now here
I can let's say I want to change the
first element of the of the file to 100
so I can just take that small section of
the file change it to 100 and then now
that change persists in the actual file
so this way I don't have to load my
entire data set into memory to operate
on it you can leave it in this huge file
and operate on specific chunks of this
file and still have those changes
persist if I want to use it later yeah
no no so here is where I create the sort
of the pointer to the file so the file
name is defined as big file and so I
created this file before because I mean
I can't create a you don't wanna create
a 10,000 by 10,000 object now so I
created the file I've said the type of
data in this file is float32 the mode is
readwrite and the shape is 10,000 by
10,000 so then this is just a pointer to
that file in memory and then here is
where I specify whatever chunks I want
to operate on
so here I've said I just want to change
the first element but I could take like
the first 10 rows and 10 columns and
then do whatever operations I want on
persistence yeah it'll just load that
that small chunk so instead of loading a
whole data you can save that by just
working on these chunks of no it's just
a normal array right you like you create
a normal array normal numpy array of
yeah there's no data format so what I
did is I created a numpy array of size
10,000 by 10,000 and then when you do
this
NP dot memory map you sort of just
well I'm sorry if I got your question
correctly you meant how did I create
this data okay I'll show you I have the
code I'll show you after it takes a bit
of time to do it so I mean I can show
you offline that's fine okay so as I'm
done with my numpy tutorials
I hope all if you guys liked it and I
really hope that some of the stuff that
I talked about today will be useful for
all of you in the work that you do and
if any of you have any questions or need
any help with anything feel free to
contact me outside of the session and
I'll be happy
[Applause]